so I came in here because I told me this
is a gourmet bacon taste test if you're
cooking with me I mean if you really
upset
everyone loves bacon it's like asking
people if they love you know oxygen of
course they do you have to they can be
asked to explain why I like chocolate
cuz it's delicious anything with grease
and fat is gonna be good it's good with
eggs it's good on a sandwich get with
chicken I could live without having
bacon but it wouldn't be very much fun
I never even thought about a world
without bacon of course we're just gonna
have bacon we're having bacon in the
morning what a Tuesday
[Music]
oh god okay I never had bacon ever again
I mean he does look delicious let's be
honest and bacon a few days ago I don't
want to say it too loud are you thinking
about are my beliefs that fragile that
one little cute thing in my arm is gonna
just change everything I know kinda yeah
bacon and steak we look at those things
those pieces of meat on our plate and
not something that wants to snuggle in
your arms how could you want to eat this
little guy look how cute he is
look at that face face you pooped on me
I take it back
eat all the pigs I'm just kidding it's
cool hey I say have all the animals that
pooped on me that's probably the most
pleasant
[Music]